-Congrats on the film.
-Thanks very much.
-This is about Molly Bloom.
This is a true life story.
-It's an absolutely true story.
Molly Bloom,
in her 20s and 30s,
ran the world's most exclusive
high-stakes poker game.
Movie stars, sports stars,
politicians,
hedge-fund managers,
they would win or lose
millions of dollars
in the course of a night,
sometimes in the course
of a hand.
And it was all legal until
she crossed a very thin line.
And even then, nobody --
She wasn't in trouble
until she unknowingly
invited four members
of the Russian Mafia
to play in the game.
-Yeah.
-That's when the FBI
got interested.
-That is a --
That is a problem.
In general,
they say the limit
is three Russian mob guys
at any --
-Yeah, and she invited four.
-The fourth one's the killer.
-And also, unknowingly,
an FBI informant.
Yeah, that's not very good.
[ Laughter ]
-And the thing is, she was --
one of her --
her expertise
was vetting players,
was knowing exactly
who was sitting at her table.
So even though she was facing
five years in jail,
she was mostly
really embarrassed.
-Yeah.
Oh, well.
This -- This movie has classic
Aaron Sorkin dialogue,
which I'm a great fan of,
but this is the first time
you directed
and you ended up directing
a script
written by Aaron Sorkin.
-Yeah.
-Did you realize now
the difficulty
that directors maybe have had
over the years
directing your scripts?
-I don't under--
[ Laughter ]
Don't understand why
at least three of them
haven't punched me in the face.
[ Laughter ]
I called --
On the second day of shooting,
I called David Fincher, who
directed "The Social Network."
And I said, "David, where do you
have the actors breathe
when they're doing my stuff?"
and this is the sound he made --
[ Chuckles mischievously ]
[ Laughter ]
-You actually had
an Oscar-winning director
on your film,
which is Kevin Costner.
-Yes.
Kevin was incredibly supportive,
incredibly encouraging.
He would remind me
from time to time that
when he directed his first film,
"Dances With Wolves,"
he had to worry about
which direction
5,000 buffalo were gonna run
when he called action.
-Yeah.
-And were they gonna come back.
[ Laughter ]
-But I talked
to a number of directors,
including a friend of yours,
Adam McKay.
-Uh-huh.
"The Big Short."
-"The Big Short."
Who was very encouraging.
Everybody --
I didn't write this movie
thinking I was gonna direct it.
When I write something,
I want the very best director
to direct it.
That's never me.
[ Light laughter ]
But I wrote it
and delivered the first draft,
and the producers encouraged me
to direct it.
And the thing is --
This is for real.
After describing all the glamour
and the decadence and the money
and the poker and everything,
the movie does have all of that,
but it's set against
the backdrop of that.
It's actually --
and this isn't a joke --
it's a Christmas movie.
-Really?
-It is a very -- Molly Bloom
is a very inspirational,
aspirational character.
And, ultimately, it's a story
about doing the right thing
when the wrong thing is
a lot easier, more profitable,
can keep you out of jail.
Basically, she refused
to dish on the players
who were playing in the game,
which is what the Justice
Department wanted her to do.
-The other amazing thing
about her story,
which is taken care of
in the film,
is that she was
an Olympic skier.
-That's right.
-So, obviously, there are many
poker scenes in the film.
Directing that requires
a level of skill,
but I imagine
the technical expertise
required to shoot a skiing scene
is more intimidating
as a first-time director.
-We were -- Yes.
Molly Bloom came --
She was ranked third
in North America
in women's moguls.
That's a form
of skiing which is
tch tch tch tch tch,
fwt fwt fwt, psh psh psh!
[ Laughter ]
It's just -- It looks like
a terrible way to die.
[ Laughter ]
And she was ranked third
in North America.
Came about 100 yards from making
the U.S. Olympic ski team,
when --
This isn't a spoiler.
It happens in
the first eight minutes.
When she literally
and metaphorically
trips over a stick
and literally and metaphorically
flies way off course
in her life.
Directing those scenes, we were
on an actual World Cup slope,
which is 52 degrees.
It's slanted about like that.
Now, I have to tell you,
honestly,
I have a problem
on a flat surface that's dry.
[ Laughter ]
I fall down
for no reason at all.
And I'm standing
on this 52-degree ice wall,
trying to confidently
give instructions to the crew,
to the stunt skiers,
to people who were used
to this kind of thing.
And I would start out,
"All right, on action,
we're gonna --" Fwt!
and I would just fall down,
and somebody would lift me up.
"Okay, sorry.
Guys, on action,
we're gonna cut --
Damn it!
[ Laughter ]
And it would
take me 10 minutes
to get a direction out
'cause I just couldn't stand up.
And, finally,
just two guys on the crew
just held me up under each arm
while I directed the movie.
It was humiliating.
-I think, you know, it's --
When you think of Molly Bloom
and this incredible story,
it almost seems sad
that a man who couldn't
even stand in snow --
-No, I couldn't even
stand in the snow.
And, by the way, also, can't --
I can't play poker.
I'm not a poker player.
But all of the extras
in the poker scenes
were professional poker players.
I wanted it that way.
Professional poker players
have a way of handling cards
and chips that's just different
from me and you.
Now, extras are paid
about $90 for a 12-hour day.
They're not paid
very much at all.
But they didn't care,
because every big-shot actor
that came in, like Michael Cera
and Chris O'Dowd,
would come in
and do their poker scenes.
Any time we were changing
lenses, changing lighting,
moving the cameras, the dealer,
who was a professional dealer,
would just start
to deal a round.
The actors would always
want to play with the pros.
The actors went home
without their pants.
[ Laughter ]
And the extras were the
highest-paid actors on the set.
-Well, there's something fitting
about that, as well.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
It's really a wonderful film.
-Thanks very much.
-Congratulations
on the Golden Globe nomination.
-I appreciate it.
Christmas Day!
-Christmas Day!
Aaron Sorkin, everybody!
"Molly's Game," Christmas Day,
nationwide on January 5th!